Swapping leather jackets for Christmas coats
– hundreds of motorbikers donned their Santa
costumes for a festive parade through Berlin,
all for a good cause: raising awareness for
those in need in their city.
"We want to step on the gas and say, take
a look, especially at Christmas.
It is, after all, the season to open your
heart and perhaps be a bit more generous."
"First of all, it’s a good thing which I’d
like to support.
And second, it's of course wonderful to ride
in such a big group.
Already on the way here, you see children
in their cars waving, taking photos, everyone
is cheerful.
That’s why I want to do it again every year."
"You ride through the city, everyone laughs
when they see us and waves, and are cheerful
and happy.
It's really great."
On their tour, bikers stop off at charities,
bringing gifts.
For this care facility for young people, they've
brought a couple of TVs.
Ahead of the parade, the bikers collected
donations to be able to fulfill.
"When people do something for other people
without expecting anything in return, but
simply to give something – that deserves
a big round of applause."
Braving frosty weather, the bikers rode for
four hours through the city.
Berlin’s bikers first came up with the idea
for a parade more than 20 years ago – back
then, there were just two of them.
Now, more than 200 bikers take part – and
hundreds more come to watch.
Berlin’s bikers have now become something
of a Christmas attraction.